Prof: So time to start.
So let me begin by reviewing a
little bit of the dynamic
hedging which I could have
described a little bit more
clearly last time.
It's a very important idea and
I made a little bit of a mess of
it.
I didn't make that big a mess
of it, but a little bit of a
mess of it.
So let's be a little bit
careful now about who knows what
and what you're doing.
So we said imagine somebody who
knows that the probability the
Yankees are going to win the
World Series is 60 percent,
and therefore each game of the
and knows that the probability
the Phillies win the game is 40
percent.
So suppose that he finds
somebody who is willing to bet
with him on the Phillies.
So he can win 100 dollars if
the Yankees win.
He has to pay 100 dollars if
the Yankees lose.
Now, his expected payoff is 20.
He should take the bet because
if the person's willing to bet
at even odds,
the Phillies fan's willing to
bet at even odds and he knows
the odds are 60/40,
on expectation he's going to
make 20.
So it's clear what he should
do, but the problem is he's
subject to risk.
Although he's right about the
odds he could still,
even though he's done the smart
thing,
he could still end up losing
100 dollars which could be a
disaster for him.
So what he would like to do is
to hedge his bets.
Now, what does it mean hedge
his bet?
Well, suppose there was another
bookie who was willing to bet at
60/40 odds in either direction
then what should he do?
Well, if he can find another
bookie who was willing to bet at
60/40 odds he should try and
lock in 20 dollars no matter
what.
So he should do this bet.
He should bet with the other
bookie 80 dollars.
He'd be willing to give up 80
dollars if the Yankees won in
order to win 120 dollars if the
Phillies win,
and that's a fair bet according
to the other bookie because it's
60/40 odds,
60 percent of this and 40
percent of that,
this is 3 to 2 odds so it's a
fair bet.
So in other words,
he makes money by taking
advantage of the Philly fan to
bet on the Yankees,
but that subjects him to risk.
So in order to minimize the
risk he hedges his bet.
That's where the expression
came from.
He hedges that bet by betting
in the opposite direction,
on--betting on the Phillies
with his bookie,
in the opposite direction,
but standing to lose less than
he,
you know, he's betting in this
proportion,
in this amount so that he gets
20 no matter what.
So he's locked in his 20-dollar
profit.
So that was where we began.
Now, let's just think about it
a little bit more carefully than
I did before.
Somebody, in fact,
basically asked this question.
Is he really making money
because he understands better
the odds of the Yankees winning
the game?
Is he making money because he
knows the odds are 60/40 and the
poor Philly fan thinks they're
50/50?
The answer is no.
That's not why he's making
money.
It doesn't matter what the odds
are of the Yankees winning.
He's winning because he's
managed to arbitrage two
different betters,
namely the Philly fan and the
other bookie,
and the fact that they differ
in their beliefs,
the fact that he can trade with
the bookie at 3 to 2 odds
whatever bet he wants,
and the Philly fan is trading
at different odds with him.
That's what enables him to make
his profit.
So how did he make the
arbitrage--so what is an
arbitrage?
An arbitrage is,
you find two bets which are
more or less the same thing,
which in fact are exactly the
same thing, but trade at a
different price.
So what are the two bets?
Well, there's the Philly bet,
the Philly fan bet,
and then there's the bookie bet
plus borrowing 20 dollars.
So he's going to make 20 for
sure.
So he could make the 20 at the
beginning just by borrowing
against his winnings.
Then he'd have 20 at the very
beginning and his payoffs from
the Philly fan bet would be
exactly--he'd owe the 20 so he'd
have minus 100.
So this bet is he'd be able to
get 20 at the beginning,
but he'd have to pay minus 100
and 100.
He'd pay 100 dollars if the
Yankees won, and get 100 dollars
if the Phillies won.
And so that way he'd cancel his
bet at the end and end up with
20 dollars for sure.
So just to say it again,
he's made money apparently
because he knows more than the
Philly fan knows,
but actually in order to
guarantee that he doesn't run a
risk he has to find another
trader,
and it's the presence of the
other trader who's really giving
him his profit opportunity,
not his superior knowledge.
And the fact that he has two
different traders--and so why
does that give him an
opportunity?
Because he can arrange a bet
with the Philly fan and a bet
with the other bookie,
but combined with borrowing the
money so that in the end he's
going to just get 0 payoffs.
Putting together the Philly fan
bet,
and the bookie fan bet,
and borrowing 20 dollars he
gets 20 dollars at the very
beginning,
and on net he has nothing at
the end,
so whatever losses he got from
the Phillies he made up from the
bookie bet.
Whatever losses he had from the
bookie bet he made up for it
with the Philly fan bet.
So arbitrage relies on
replication.
Somehow through some other
bet--he was able to hedge his
other bet.
He was able to hedge his
Phillies bet by replicating the
bet with somebody else combined
with borrowing to produce
exactly the same payoffs in the
end,
or the negative of the payoffs
in the end,
and yet for a different price
at the beginning.
The Philly fan didn't demand
any money upfront to make this
(100, minus 100) bet with him.
And with the bookie he's able
to get 20 dollars upfront and
make this the opposite bet,
the (minus 100,100) bet.
So by getting more money
upfront and doing the opposite
bet with the bookie he can end
up completely canceling the
Philly bet,
Philly fan bet,
and that's how he makes his
profit.
So that was the first idea.
So what have I clarified?
What I've clarified is that it
wasn't his superior knowledge,
it was the presence of two
different traders that enabled
him to make his profit,
and I've clarified the method
that he made the profit.
The profit wasn't just kind of
mixing in another bet,
it was really cleverly
arranging to undo totally the
original bet.
So he got actually 0 in the end
and ended up with 20 dollars at
the beginning.
So let's just see now what you
would do in a dynamic situation.
Yes?
Student: I apologize.
I understand how this locks him
into that $20 dollars,
and how it makes sure he
doesn't incur the losses that he
might have occurred,
but why would he do this if he
has 20 dollars at the beginning
and all this does is make sure
no matter what he ends up with
the 20 dollars at the end?
Prof: Why would he do
what at all?
Student: This arbitrage
at all, any of the bets.
It seems like no matter what
whether the Yankees or lose he
ends up with 20 dollars.
Why didn't he just keep his 20
dollars and not bet?
Prof: He didn't have 20
dollars to begin with.
He had no dollars.
So he went and found the Philly
fan and he made a bet against
the Philly fan with no money.
The Philly fan was willing to
bet him 100 dollars on the
Phillies.
So he gets 100 if the Yankees
win.
He pays the fan 100 if the
Phillies win.
It didn't cost any money to do
that.
Then he goes out and makes
another bet with the bookie.
Again, it doesn't cost him any
money.
He gives up 80 dollars if the
Yankees win, but he gets $120 if
the Phillies win.
So he's spent no money at all
and his total profit is 20
dollars for sure.
So what could he do since he
knows he's going to make 20
dollars for sure in the future?
He could just borrow it at the
beginning if the interest rate's
0,
have 20 dollars at the
beginning, end up with 0 no
matter what the uncertainty is
and put the 20 dollars in his
pocket.
So that's another way of saying
the same thing which is that he
could,
by combining the bets,
put money in his pocket in at
the beginning and no matter what
happens in the future he doesn't
have to give anybody any more
money.
So that's what he's done.
That's what an arbitrage is.
You put money in your pocket in
the present and in the future
you never have to face a
problem.
You've always got money that's
going out in one hand you're
getting from the other hand.
Now, in a dynamic situation you
can do the same thing.
So I'm just reinterpreting what
we did before a little bit.
So in the dynamic situation
what are you doing?
The Philly fan now is betting
on the whole World Series even
though you know the odds are
60/40.
So now that's an even worse bet
by the Philly fan if you're
right about the odds because the
chances are even higher that the
Yankees are going to win the
series than one game.
The odds, we know,
are 71 percent.
So by backward induction we did
this calculation to say your
expected payoff is 42 dollars.
So let's suppose now--but now
the key is that you're making
money not just because you know
better what the odds are,
you're making money because
there's another bookie standing
there always ready to trade with
you at 60/40 odds in any game.
So the presence of the second
bookie, even if you knew
nothing, would enable you to
make money in this case,
lock in a profit for sure of 42
dollars.
Now, how do you know that you
can lock in a profit for sure of
42 dollars?
Well, it's now done by dynamic
hedging.
You have to lay off part of
your bet,
a little part each day,
each game and the amount that
you lay off is going to depend
on what happens,
so that's why it's dynamic.
It's a complicated calculation.
So it seems almost hopeless to
figure out what to do.
I'm betting on the whole series.
Many different things can
happen.
The Phillies could win the
first game.
The Yankees could win the first
game.
Lots of things could happen.
By the end I want to make sure
I've locked in my profit for
sure.
How can I do that?
Well, the key is to think about
marking to market.
Just as we said,
if you're assessing your
position correctly,
even though the World Series
takes 7 games,
if you were reporting to your
investors,
your hedge fund,
you're reporting to your
investors how you're doing,
you should be telling them
after the first game,
you know, at the beginning
you're telling them,
"Look, I'm going to make
42 dollars.
I expect to make 42
dollars."
After the Yankees win the first
game it looks like you're going
to make 60,
you know, now things are
better, you expect to make 64
dollars on average,
but if the Yankees lost the
first game you'd only expect to
make 9 dollars on average.
So after the first game you go
from thinking you're going to
make 42 to being even more
optimistic now,
you're going to make 64 or
you're going to make 9.
So 60 percent times 64 40
percent of 9 is 42.
So if you were telling your
investors properly how you stood
after the very first game you
might have to tell them you've
lost 33 of the 42 dollars that
you told them before you were
going to make.
So you'd already be running a
risk.
You really only care,
maybe, about getting money for
sure by the end,
but if you're doing proper
accounting you should be worried
all the way along whether you're
making or losing money.
And that's the key to how to
have no risk by the end.
You just run no risk at all the
in between stages.
So all you have to do is make a
bet with the bookie who's
standing by to make 33 dollars
in case the Phillies win the
first game.
You're making a one game bet in
exchange for losing 22 dollars
if the Yankees win.
This is still 3 to 2 odds,
so the bookie's willing to do
it.
So the night before the first
game you've bet with the Philly
fan on the entire series,
which is giving you a huge
advantage,
but you're willing to bet with
the other bookie.
The other bookie,
we're assuming,
is only standing by game by
game.
You're betting 33 to 22 on the
Phillies.
You're betting on the team you
expect to lose.
You're betting on that team
with the other bookie,
but in a smaller quantity.
So this is going to mean that
your profit after the first
game, no matter what happens,
is still going to be 42.
So you can lock in 42 after
every game.
And so as I said last time the
crucial thing is--so then one
thing I didn't say.
So one thing which I forgot to
observe last time,
which I think is interesting,
is so is that what you should
do?
Should you do that after every
game, always bet 33 to 22
against the Yankees with the
other bookie?
Well, the answer is no.
What should you do if the
Yankees win the first game?
By winning the first game your
expectation goes up to 64.
Now it could be either 82--and
the night after the first game
you're much better off than you
were before.
Of course you laid off part of
the bet with the other bookie,
so you've had to pay off 22 so
you're still only 42 ahead,
but the Yankees have now won
the first game.
So it's now the night after the
first game, before the second
game.
You're subject to more risk.
What should you do now?
You should go back to the
bookie and make another bet on
the second game,
but should the other bet be 22
to 33?
Absolutely not,
because 64 up here goes to
whatever that number is,
which I forgot already,
82 and 1 half to 36 and 1 half.
So what should you do?
What should you do now?
So I've done some rounding here
which is going to screw
everything up a little bit,
but now what should you do
here?
After the first game you're
here.
Here you are after the first
game.
You've made your bet with the
bookie.
The first game you bet 33
against 22.
Now what should you do the
second game?
What should your bet be with
that bookie?
He's still willing to give you
3 to 2 odds on the Yankees
either direction.
What should you do?
You're not going to bet (33,22)
again.
You're going to make a
different bet,
and what should it be?
Yes?
Student:
>
Prof: Exactly.
You should give up 18 if
Yankees win and get 27 rounding
up.
She conveniently rounded a
little bit because I had rounded
a little bit.
So you should do 18 and 27.
Now notice that's still 3 to 2
odds.
So the bookie's still willing
to do that for you and you're
locking in the 64 because it's
going to be 64 again,
and adding this is 64 again,
right?
So you've locked in whatever
this number is.
So in the first step you made a
bet to lock this number in.
In the second step you made a
You're always locking in where
you were before.
So that bet is changing each
time,
but you're always locking in
what you were before,
because after the Yankees have
won a game now the next game is
not quite as important.
Time is running out on the
Phillies so it's not as
revealing the next game about
what's going to happen.
So you make a smaller bet up
here than you did before.
So why is that locking
everything in?
Because this average is now 64,
what it was here,
but don't forget you'd already
made the initial bet to lose 22.
So you've locked in 44 now here
and also 44 here because you
still owe the 22 from the first
bet.
So you just keep proceeding
down the tree locking in where
you were before and so by
induction you've locked in 42.
So that's what you're doing,
and the bet is changing every
time.
So what do you think the bet is
here, by the way?
The bet here you could go from
9 to 36 or minus 32.
So what should you do here?
What should you do here?
What's the bet that you're
going to make with the bookie
after the Phillies win the first
game?
So it's going to be minus 27
and plus 41, and that's 3 to 2
odds with some rounding,
right, 13 and 1 half times 3 is
40 and 1 half.
So it's still fair odds,
so the bookie's willing to do
that.
You've locked in 9.
So by induction you've always
locked in where you were before
and therefore you've locked in
42 all the way along.
It sounds like we're locking in
9,
but we're not locking in 9
because remember the first day
you won 33 dollars from the
bookie when the Phillies won the
first game.
So you've locked in the 9,
but don't forget the 33 from
before, so it's really you've
locked in 42.
So 42's locked in the whole way.
So that's dynamic hedging.
You have a complicated bet that
depends on a lot of things along
the way,
but you bet each time along the
way,
maybe changing your bet each
time depending on what's
happened so far,
and that way you can lock in
whatever profit you had.
So that's the thing that sports
bookies have known for a long
time.
The expression "hedging
your bets"
comes from that and so that
same logic can be applied to the
market.
But remember,
the step that I didn't
emphasize very much is that
although you seem to be locking
in where you were before,
there's a slightly more
abstract way of saying that,
that at the end you're going to
get 42 dollars for sure.
So of course you could borrow
all the way back from the
beginning and get 42 dollars
immediately and then never owe
anything in the future,
because whatever bet you were
winning or losing with the
Philly fan you were making up
for with your myriad bets with
the bookie.
So it's a replication argument
that by betting sequentially
with the bookie different
amounts,
you're undoing the single long
bet you had with the Philly fan.
So now let's move from sports,
as we did last time,
to the market.
So here we had the prepayment
spreadsheet.
And so we had,
remember, this was a bond,
a mortgage, a 30-year mortgage,
8 percent mortgage,
and the interest rate started
off at 6 percent and it had a 20
percent volatility.
So the interest rates could
follow this process.
There you see it.
They start at 6 percent,
but they can go up or down by
20 percent, basically every
period.
So you assume that everybody
knows this and knows that the
probabilities are 50/50.
That's like saying you know in
advance there's a bookie out
there,
that is the market,
that's willing to give you,
no matter what day it is,
50/50 odds of the interest rate
going up or down from then on.
That's just like the bookie
standing by.
You now are going to take
advantage of the fact that you
can anticipate that the market
will stand there ready to bet
with you.
Now, if the whole market
freezes or something you can be
totally screwed.
You're doing your complicated
dynamic betting with the market,
one day you wake up and you
can't bet anymore because
nobody's willing to trade,
something horrible has
happened, 9/11 happened or
something like that.
You can be caught in a really
bad situation and end up running
a lot of risk.
So you're relying on the
market, so it's not surprising
that when the market freezes up
lots of people suddenly are
exposed to more risk than they
were before.
So now in the market you're not
going to be able to find these
pure arbitrages.
In the sports example it was a
pure arbitrage.
There was a Philly fan who is
betting at even odds and a
bookie who was betting at 3 to 2
odds.
Now, you shouldn't expect that
to happen.
I mean, by what miracle did
this fan come to you instead of
to the other bookie?
Why do you deserve to meet this
fan and take advantage of him?
What have you got that no other
bookie has?
It's a miracle he came to you
and not to one of the other
hundred bookies.
Well, it's probably because you
actually know something that the
other bookies don't that you can
take advantage of.
So in the background here
there's another thing that you
knew.
You knew the fan was going to
pay off if he lost.
Maybe the other bookies weren't
willing to bet with him because
they didn't think he was going
to pay off if he lost.
So that's the extra thing that
you knew, you knew that he was
going to pay off.
Now it makes sense that he came
to you and not to the other
bookies because you actually
knew something that they don't.
And so that's how it really
works in the market.
You're relying on some piece of
information you have that they
don't.
Of course you could be wrong
about that information and then
you get into a lot of trouble.
So here in this mortgage what's
the thing that you're relying
on?
I'm assuming that the rest of
the market is standing by ready,
as I said, to trade,
to make interest rate bets with
you,
with everybody,
at even odds whether the
interest rate's going to go up
or down.
So no matter where you find
yourself in the future,
like here, someone is willing
to bet at 50/50 odds that it
will go up or down.
Now, this is a year-long bet so
you're going to have to take
into account the interest rate.
It's not just going to be 50/50.
You have to discount all the
cash flows by the interest rate,
but it's basically a 50/50 bet
discounted by the interest rate.
So now what's new here?
Well, you don't know what the
cash flows are.
So here's the extra piece of
information you're adding.
You know that the mortgage
homeowner is rational and is
going to prepay rationally.
So you know what these cash
flows are.
Some of the time the mortgage
homeowner is going to pay the 8
dollars he owes,
some of the time he's just
going to pay 8 dollars,
in fact, here is what you know
is going to happen.
Down here where the 1s are he's
going to pay his coupon of 8,
pay off the remaining principal
and that's the end of it.
So in fact the very first day
if interest rates went down the
rational thing to do is to pay
off the entire mortgage.
So you know that's going to
happen.
Now, that's the extra
information you have.
You know what the cash flows
are.
If other people knew those cash
flows they would figure out the
price of the mortgage too.
It's just they don't know those.
You know the cash flows and you
can now figure out that the
price better be 98.
Why--if there's someone else
willing to trade with you to buy
that mortgage for more than 98,
like why might that happen?
Because someone else might have
the erroneous opinion that the
homeowner will never call the
mortgage,
will never prepay because he's
just going to be asleep all the
time.
So let's say the homeowner's a
she.
Let's say the homeowners are
all shes.
This other trader thinks
they're all asleep and will
never prepay.
You know that these homeowners
are all incredibly alert and on
top of things,
and so they're going to prepay,
and the value's only 98.
So because of that extra
information you know the actual
cash flows.
Sorry, we're here.
You know the cash flows.
You know how to value the bond,
and you know it's worth 98.
So, and let's say the other
guy's willing to pay you 120 for
it.
So you can sell it short.
You can sell it to the guy
short for 120.
That means you owe whatever
cash flows the mortgage pays,
and you know what it's going to
pay down there.
So how can you lock in your
profit?
Well, because with 98 dollars
at the very beginning you can
replicate those cash flows.
You can go out into the market
and buy those cash flows,
the very cash flows you know
the mortgage is going to make.
How can you do that?
Well, because at the first
step--remember what this says.
The first step the price is 98.
The interest rate could go up
or down.
If the interest rate goes up
the payment is 8.
That's the coupon plus 92
something;
92.6, and if it goes down the
payment is 8.
So what is this?
The payment is actually 8.
That's the cash flow that has
to be made.
The mortgage wasn't called here
at the beginning so no matter
what she does,
the homeowner,
she's got to pay the 8.
So you know you're going to owe
the guy 8 the first period.
Now, down here she's actually
going to prepay.
So she's actually going to pay
the guy the whole 99.1.
Up here she's not going to
prepay.
She's going to hang onto the
mortgage.
So what is this 92.6?
This is the present value,
assuming those cash flows,
of her future payments.
So if you get 98 dollars you
know that 1 half times this--
this by the way,
is 102.6, so 1 half times this
divided by 1.06 plus this thing,
remember is 107.11 divided by
1.06 times 1 half.
That's how we got the number
98,98.8 whatever it was.
That's how you calculated 98.8
by backward induction.
You took this value times 1
half discounted plus this value
times 1 half discounted.
That's how you got 98.8.
So therefore,
if people are willing to trade
at these prices,
in other words what's the price
here?
It's 1 half times 1 over 1.06
and this is 1 half times 1 over
1.06.
You can buy 1 dollar here at a
cost of 1 half times 1.06.
cost of 1 half divided by 1.06.
Paying this amount at the
beginning will buy you 1 dollar
here.
Paying this amount at the
beginning will buy you 1 dollar
here.
So by paying this amount you
can get this payoff,
102.6,100.6,
sorry, 100.6.
You can get this 100.6 and you
can get 107.11 because precisely
this is the cost that you have
to pay for each dollar up here,
and this is the cost that you
have to pay here for each dollar
down here.
Why is that?
Because we said the market is
standing by recognizing that
these are 50/50 odds that it has
to discount.
So that means the whole market
is willing to trade you,
will be willing to promise you
1 dollar here in exchange for
this amount of dollars here.
It'll be willing to promise you
1 dollar here in exchange for
this amount of dollars here.
So with this amount of dollars
you can buy 8 dollars and have
92.6 leftover and you can also
buy 8 dollars here with 99.11
leftover.
So all this together is enough
to make the prepayment because
you know she's going to prepay
here.
That's what we found out.
She's going to prepay at the
first step down.
Oh, what the hell does this say?
She's prepaying just as we said.
At the very first step she's
prepaying.
The first interest rate down
she's going to prepay.
So we know you're going to have
to come up with all this money,
but you've bought it over here.
It cost you this amount.
You bought all that.
If things went up you'd have to
pay 8,
which you've also bought,
but you've got 92.6 left over
and that's going to be enough to
buy everything that comes after
that because the next day you're
going to have to buy more stuff,
and so you just keep buying
going forward.
So with 98.8 dollars you can
buy all the future cash flows
and you've sold the thing so you
can make all your payments that
you're obliged to by selling it
short and you received 120 to
begin with.
So you locked in 21.2 dollars.
So that's the gist of the whole
thing.
So I said it last time not very
well.
I said it a little bit better
this time, still not
brilliantly, but do you now get
it?
Someone ask me a question
perhaps?
Is it okay?
So I'll say the punch line
again.
The punch line is that if you
can find a favorable--so here
what was different about the
World Series and the mortgage
example?
In the World Series you took
advantage of the fact that there
was a bookie and a Philly fan
willing to bet at different odds
on the same thing,
and so even though the Philly
fan had a very complicated 7 day
bet,
and the other bookies were only
willing to make day by day bets,
you could take advantage of
that disparity to lock in a
profit for sure,
and that's what you should try
to do.
In the market you're probably
relying on something else.
You're relying on the fact that
you know more about the cash
flows than the rest of the
traders do,
the rest of the market does,
maybe because you understand
prepayments better than they do.
And so that's why I said it was
so important to model
prepayments.
So let's say you understand
prepayments better than they do
so you know what the cash flows
are going to be much better than
the market does.
You can take advantage of that.
You need now this advantage.
Just like in the World Series
you might have needed the
advantage of knowing the Philly
fan would actually pay off if he
lost.
So there's that advantage that
you have,
and now you have to rely on the
fact that the market or the
bookie from then on day by day,
year by year,
is willing to make bets at
these odds that you can
anticipate.
And so using that you can trade
over and over again with the
rest of the market and
dynamically replicate what the
payments you have to make by
selling the bond short.
So therefore you've locked in
your profit because you can
anticipate--
assuming the market stays there
willing to trade at even odds
you'll always be able to produce
the cash flows with the 98
dollars you started with to
exactly meet all your payment
obligations you've incurred by
selling the mortgage short.
And since you sold it at the
beginning for $120 you've made
21 dollars at the beginning and
you'll never need those dollars.
You just put them in your
pocket.
So that's how to dynamically
hedge a winning position to
eliminate the chance of loss.
Of course you still bear a
chance of loss.
If you're wrong about the
prepayments you're going to lose
money,
and if the rest of the market
suddenly stops being there to
make these year by year bets on
which way interest rates are
going to go you'll also be
subject to a lot of risk.
So you're relying on those two
things,
the whole market not collapsing
and your being right about
prepayments,
but conditional on those two
facts you've locked in your
profit.
So you got rid of a bunch of
risk, the blind luck of (100,
minus 100) from the roll of the
dice of the Phillies.
You got rid of that luck,
but you still had to count on
the bookie being there day after
day after day,
and in the mortgage case on the
fact that you knew how to
predict the prepayments.
Yes?
Student: So in the first
example,
what's the point of betting the
second time since the maximum
amount of money we can make is
42,
and we already made it in first
bet,
so why should I come to you
betting?
Prof: I never made 42 on
the first bet.
Here at the beginning nothing's
happened yet.
The series hasn't been played
yet.
So I say to myself I've made
this 100-dollar bet with the
Philly fan for the whole series
on who's going to win the
series.
That's going to happen 7 days
later.
So right now I can anticipate,
on average I'll make 42
dollars.
Some of the time I'll lose 100.
Some of the time I'll win 100,
but on average I'll come out 42
dollars ahead.
So I've done a smart thing
betting with the naive Philly
fan, but I'm still potentially
screwed.
I could still lose 100 dollars.
I'll still have to face my
investors and tell them I've
lost all your money.
They're going to close me down,
and so I don't want to run that
risk.
They don't want me to run that
risk and I don't want to run the
risk.
I still want to take advantage
of the Philly fans.
So what I do is every game I
make another bet against my
inclination.
I bet not on the Phillies,
I bet, I mean,
not on the Yankees who I think
they're going to win,
I'm betting on the Phillies
because I'm undoing part of the
gamble that I did with this guy.
I'm hedging that gamble,
but by doing that in a clever
way,
changing how much money I bet
each game--
so the night before the first
game I bet 33 dollars to 22
dollars on the Phillies winning.
After the Yankees win the first
game I bet 27 dollars to 18
dollars again on the Phillies
winning.
So I decrease my bet going up,
I increase it going down.
So by doing these clever game
by game bets I lock in 42
dollars for sure.
Yes?
Student: Do you actually
lock in for sure because say at
the end of the last round you
don't actually--
like that node is going to be
the end, right?
You don't actually have two
branches coming out of it,
>
favorable outcome and
Prof: So you have locked
it in.
So how could that be?
So it's a good question,
but you've overlooked
something.
So her question is the game's
going to end after 7 days.
What if I ended with the minus
100?
The Phillies won all four games.
Doesn't it look like I've lost?
So why didn't I lose?
I bet 100 dollars with the
original Phillies fan.
I bet 100 dollars on the
Yankees.
If the Phillies win all first
four games I've got to give the
guy 100 dollars.
Of course I made these side
bets with all these bookies on
the way.
So what were the side bets?
Student: Sorry.
My question is the only nodes
that are secured,
that are locked in,
are nodes with two branches
coming out of it.
There's going to be an end
where there's no more branches
coming out of the node and so
what's the situation?
Prof: The situation is
you're up 42 dollars,
but we're trying to understand
why that is.
That's your question, right?
So you're going to be able to
answer the question although you
don't think so yet.
So what happened the first time?
The first time the Phillies
won, that bet with the original
Philly fan is looking worse.
I had 42 dollars I expected to
win.
Now I only expect to win 9
dollars because the series is
turning against me,
but the bookie paid me 33
dollars.
So I'm--33 dollars already in
my pocket.
This is 9.
Now let's say I got to the end
to the last game where this was
a 0.
Let's say this was the last
game where I've lost.
Well, this is minus 32.
Let's say this is the last game.
I lose 32 dollars here.
Let's say it was only a two
game series and I give up 32
dollars in case the Phillies win
the first two games,
right?
So you're saying,
"I'm down 32 dollars.
That's the last node.
How can I possibly be up
42?"
Well, so what's the answer?
Student: Because I
hedged it with the bookies.
Prof: What?
Student: Because I
hedged it with the bookies.
Prof: Right,
because I bet on the first game
and the first bookie gave me 33
dollars.
Then the second game I'm going
to bet with the bookies and I'm
going to bet minus 27 and 41.
So although I now owe the
Philly fan 33 dollars here,
I made 41 dollars with the
second bookie and 33 dollars
with the first bookie.
That's 74 dollars and I pay 32
to the original Philly fan so
I'm still up 42 dollars.
So it sounds like you have to
do a lot of arithmetic.
You don't have to do any
arithmetic.
I knew I was going to end up 42
dollars up.
How is that?
Because every bet I said let's
look at the number here wherever
we are on the tree like here.
At this node after all the
stuff that's happened before the
bet I'm going to make with the
bookie that one game is going to
be enough to turn this random
thing into 64/64.
So I always take what happens
further down the tree and turn
it into what's happened at the
beginning of the tree,
but then I work it all the way
back and it's 42.
So that means,
see this thing was 64 and 9,
but I made a bet 22/33 with the
bookie to turn it into 42/42.
This thing was 64.
I made a bet to turn this into
64/64, but with the 22 here
that's also 42.
So no matter how far I go on
the tree I'm still exactly 42
ahead.
Any other questions?
Yes?
Student: In the example
that we just did for the
mortgage, could you explain why
we are gaining 8 dollars?
I thought we'd be losing 8
dollars every branch.
It's below the...
Prof: Sorry,
what am I doing?
Student: In each branch
we've said that we're gaining 8
dollars 92.6.
Aren't we doing negative 8 92.6?
Prof: So her question is
in this case the mortgage--so
now we're moving from the World
Series to more real life.
In this case I know the cash
flows from this mortgage are
worth 98.8,
but somebody else not
understanding the homeowner and
how rational she is,
someone else is willing to pay
me 120 for that mortgage.
So I sell the mortgage for 120
and I take 21 dollars and put it
in my pocket.
Now I've got 98.8 dollars left.
So that's money now I have to
do something active with.
What do I have to do?
I owe this guy a lot of
payments.
Every time she,
let's say it's you,
makes your payment,
her payment,
in the market I've sold the
thing short.
That means I owe--I've promised
to deliver whatever that
mortgage delivers.
That's what it means to sell it
short.
So I've got to deliver the 8
here, say.
I've got to deliver the 8 here,
and here she's prepaying.
I have to deliver the whole
107, right?
So with 98.8 dollars I can
afford to buy 100.6 dollars in
this state and 107.11 in this
state.
How do I know that,
because that's where the 98.8
came from.
It said this total amount 100.6
times the price,
which is the odds of it
happening discounted,
that's the price plus the
107.11 times its price,
the odds it happens discounted,
is exactly 98.8.
That's where I got 98.8.
So therefore with 98.8 dollars,
remember the bookie's willing
to go either way,
with 98.8 dollars I can buy all
these cash flows and all these
cash flows.
So what do I do?
With the 107.1 down here I pay
the 8, her coupon,
and her 99.11 prepayment.
I pay it all to that guy I sold
the bond short to and I've kept
my promise.
That's the end of the mortgage.
Up here the mortgage only
delivered 8 so I only owe him 8,
but I've got another 92.6 left.
Why is that exactly what I need?
Because from here on I have to
use that money to buy the future
cash flows because she's going
to continue to pay her 8 and
maybe eventually it will prepay.
But by induction,
by repeating this step over and
over again I can always make the
payment and have the present
value left over to afford to buy
the future payments plus the
present value left over.
So by induction I'm always
making the coupon.
Like in this first step I make
the coupon payment plus I've got
enough money left over to match
the present value.
So that means as I go forward,
and forward,
and forward I keep making the
payment and matching the present
value that's left over.
By the time I get to the 30th
year I've made the coupon
payment.
The present value left over is
0 because there isn't going to
be any payments after that.
So I've made all the payments.
Student: Could you do
this one year ahead as well?
Prof: Yes, I could.
So I was hoping you wouldn't
ask me that because it's--so
what happens in the next period.
So here we know that she didn't
pay.
She didn't prepay.
The present value is 92.6,
so we're here,
92.6.
Now, she didn't pay.
Let's look at what she's doing,
whether she's prepaying or not.
So this is why I did the second
graph.
So if the interest rates go up
the first time and then back
down she's still not going to
prepay.
So we can now go up and
see--oops.
Here we are.
So we can go up now and see
what's happening here.
It's 92.65.
You go up to 83.95 or down to
97.2.
97.17.
So what does that mean?
So with 98.8 dollars I bought,
I'm the guy selling the thing
short, you're the smart rational
pre-payer, so you paid 8 dollars
here.
That means because I've sold
the mortgage short and you've
made that 8-dollar payment I owe
the guy the 8-dollar payment
just as if he had the mortgage.
So I've got to come up with the
8 dollars.
Down here if things had moved
here you would have paid 8
dollars plus the whole
prepayment so you would have
paid 107 dollars.
But with 98.8 I can buy 8 92.6
up here and 8 99.11 down here.
So I've bought all the cash
flows I need to down here.
I hand them over to the guy and
I say,
"You see,
I kept my promise to deliver
whatever that mortgage did,
and I knew that she was going
to prepay,
I knew how smart she was and so
I've kept my promise.
You didn't think she'd prepay.
I knew it.
I've kept my promise."
And then up here I've got the 8
dollars so I can make the
payment, match it.
I've got 92.6 left,
now I don't give it to the guy
because the payment's only been
8.
I take the 92.6 and with the
92.6 that happens to equal this
plus 8 times 1 half divided by
1.06,
and it equals,
also, this plus 8 times 1 half
divided by 1.06.
Not by 1.06,
by the interest rate here which
happens to be--you have to
figure out what that interest
rate was up there.
So the interest rate went up
to--it started at 6 percent and
went up to 0732 percent.
So this is .0732.
How did this number 92.6 get
calculated?
It was exactly take the payment
of 8,
take the present value of
what's left,
multiply by 1 half and discount
it at the interest rate here
plus 1 half times this payment
of 8 plus the value of what's
left discounted by that interest
rate.
So this number 92.6 allows me
to buy this and to buy that.
So therefore,
if things went up again I could
make your 8-dollar payment that
you make to the bank I have to
make to the other guy because I
sold the mortgage short.
I've got the money to pay him.
I've also got the money to pay
him if things had gone down
again 8 dollars.
And I've got more cash in my
pocket, this and this in the two
cases.
With this money I can continue
to buy the future payments that
you're going to make.
So I always have enough money
to make whatever payments it is
that I have to,
to keep my promise.
Yep?
Student: Is it sort of
preferable from your point of
view that the interest rate go
up because your theory about
prepayments isn't going to be
put to the test?
Prof: Well,
don't forget,
I'm locking in my 21 dollar
profit for sure,
so no matter what happens I'm
going to just be able to make
all the payments no matter what.
Student: But now it
seems that your theory about
prepayments is...
Prof: Correct, yes.
Student: So it's like
ambiguity, right?
Not just the rest is like
ambiguity, so it's sort of
preferable...
Prof: So good.
So let me repeat his question,
if he'll forgive me,
in slightly different words.
He's saying that I was able to
take--this is what my hedge fund
does, literally.
We think we know better what
the prepayments are going to be
than the rest of the market,
so we're willing to take on a
commitment--
someone will pay us 120 dollars.
We think 98 dollars are enough
to buy all the promises that
we've made by selling the thing
short, say.
We could be wrong.
We have been wrong.
The last two years we made a
lot of mistakes.
So you're saying,
the question is,
the reason why the guy is
willing to pay so much is
because down here he thinks he's
going to get a lot of money.
The interest rates are going
down so, discounting at a lower
rate, the mortgage is going to
be worth a lot more.
We don't think it's going to be
more because we're expecting
prepayments.
Up here it's sort of obvious
that there aren't going to be
any prepayments.
So if the world really goes,
interest rates going up,
then our theory of prepayments
never gets put to the test and
so we just make money.
So our theory never gets put to
the test.
If interest rates go down then
our theory's been really put to
the test and we have to see
whether she's really smart
enough to prepay or not.
So you're right.
That's absolutely true, yep.
But in any case we're going to
assume our theory is correct and
hedge in such a way so that if
our theory is correct about
prepayments we will exactly be
in a position to keep our
promises without ever running a
risk of loss.
Yes?
Student: So with the
World Series example.
So let's say there are two
situations where the Phillies
win in 4 games or they win the
series in 5 games.
Either way you lose 100 dollars
and you win 4 single game bets,
but in one of the situations
you've lost one single game bet
because the Phillies won in 5
games rather than 4.
How do the values reconcile?
Prof: Because it
couldn't have happened that
there were four straight wins
and then a loss.
The series would have been
over, right?
So his question is I've
asserted that no matter what way
things go I'm going to end up 42
dollars ahead no matter what,
and he's saying that's great,
but he's a little skeptical it
could be true because I'm always
betting against this other
bookie.
I'm always betting on the
Phillies with the other bookie,
and so in one case the Yankees
win 4 in a row.
I lose 4 bets with the other
bookie, with the bookie I'm
betting on the Phillies,
so I've had to take 4 losing
bets with the other bookie.
In the case where the Yankees
win three lose one and then win
in the end I've again lost 4
bets with the other bookie,
but I've actually won a bet
with the other bookie.
So it seems like somehow things
are better for me,
so it seems unbelievable that
I'm still at 42 in both cases.
That's your question, right?
So the reason is that my bets
are changing.
I don't make the same last bet.
So the first three bets there's
a Yankee win,
Yankee win, Yankee win,
each of those nights I'm making
the same bet in the same
scenario,
but when the Phillies lose and
then win again I've changed my
bet,
so I'm still going to end
up--so the Yankees lost the,
your scenario was the Yankees
lost the 4th game,
so that outcome is different
from what it would have been in
the first scenario because the
Yankees lost instead of winning.
So the bookie bet went the
other way.
But now the last bet I made is
not the same bet as I would have
made the night before.
It's a different bet so that it
just ends up with a different
direction than the 4th bet plus
this different 5th bet it adds
back up to what would have
happened had the Yankees won the
fourth time.
I don't know if that helps,
but that's what happens.
And the proof that it happens
is just by induction.
I gave a proof and you're
saying the proof is amazingly
good.
Remember, the proof is very
simple.
You always make a bet so that
no matter what happens your
expectation is back to where it
was the night before.
And if you do that you have to
end up--that's the proof that
you've always locked in 42 from
the beginning.
And so you can ask a thousand
questions like that and it's
always going to be a complicated
answer,
but there has to be an answer
because we've proved that there
was one.
Any other questions about this?
Yes?
Student:
So with the mortgage example
you're hedging against the
interest rate going up.
Prof: So with the
mortgage example you're hedging
against the interest rate
going--no.
When the interest rate goes up
you actually pay less.
You've made a promise.
Remember, the price as the
interest rate goes up--where's
the mortgage,
sorry.
The value of the non-call,
the value of the call,
so as the interest rate goes up
you owe less money because
you're promising to deliver this
stuff.
So the interest rate's up,
the mortgage you've sold short
is less and less valuable,
so that's the good scenario for
you,
but if the interest rate goes
down that's the scenario where
you could get into trouble.
So you're trying to protect
against the interest rate going
down,
and in order to do that you
have to give money up in case
the interest rate goes up.
So now I want to--any other
questions about this?
It's quite an ingenious thing,
I think.
So we're going to have one more
step of this,
but this is the high watermark
of the standard,
you know, the finance guys who
made finance such an important
subject,
and the rational expectations
school of finance.
This is kind of the most clever
thing that they did.
So this kind of reasoning,
bookies maybe knew it for a
long time,
but Black-Scholes in 1973
started this kind of thinking
and then lots of hedge funds
started imitating it including
my own.
So I certainly didn't invent
this idea of dynamic hedging.
Now, let's take a step back.
The crucial idea is marking to
market.
The crucial idea is that you
want to hedge something through
millions of scenarios and really
the outcome you won't know until
the end.
What you should do is hedge at
each step of the way your mark
to market value.
So you only have to do things a
step at a time.
There's an exponentially
growing number of paths,
but there are only two
possibilities from today until
tomorrow.
So it's very simple to hedge
two things.
It seems incredibly complicated
to hedge 2 to the 100 things,
2 to the 10th is a very big
number, 2 is a very small
number.
You can hedge two things.
It may be very complicated to
hedge 2 to the 10 things,
but you only have to hedge 2
things on every day.
So once you've realized that,
hedging is actually quite a
simple operation.
You don't have to do it by
trading in the interest rate
derivatives market.
You could trade in a simpler
market.
Suppose, for example,
that you knew that there were
bonds being traded,
let's say 30-year bonds.
So let's just take a look at a
30-year bond here,
callable bond,
so this is exactly the same
thing.
This is the 30-year bond under
the same circumstance.
This is a 9 percent bond,
coupon bond,
and it's starting with the same
6 percent interest rates,
exactly the same process as
before.
So the interest rates,
those are the same interest
rates as before.
So here's the bond.
Now, the bond starts at 140
dollars, can go to 121 dollars
or to 159 dollars.
Remember this thing that you're
trying to hedge goes from 98.8
to 100.6 or to 107.11.
So what you need to do now
is--you've promised to make
deliveries in the future,
very complicated,
but you know you can summarize
that whole future.
As long as you've got 100.6
dollars in the up state and
107.11 dollars in the down state
after the very first step you
will have hedged your mortgage
obligation.
But you could just buy the
right percentage of bonds and be
able to accomplish the same
thing.
So why is that?
Well, there's a gap here and
here.
You owe less money here than
you do down there.
So the bond is worth less up
here than down here.
In fact this bond is worth 38
dollars more here than here.
So the gap in the bond is 38.
The gap in here is something
like 6.5.
So this is like 1 sixth.
So as long as you held 1 sixth
of the bond and something that
paid the right constant amount
in each case you would get the
same payments here and here.
So what is the right constant
amount?
1 sixth of the bond,
by the way, would cost you
22,24, 23, about 23 dollars,
1 sixth of the bond.
So if you took the other 98.8
dollars and put it to the 1 year
Treasury,
I claim it's obvious--so take 1
sixth of the--
so 1 sixth of 30 year 9 percent
bond.
That's 1 sixth of this thing,
which costs you what?
It cost 23 dollars.
The price of that is 23 dollars.
Now, combine that with 75.8
dollars of 1 year Treasury,
1 year 6 percent Treasury.
So hold those two things.
I claim that'll pay you 100.6
here and 107.11 here.
How do I know that without
having to even calculate
anything out?
Well, the Treasury's going to
pay the same amount here and
here.
It's going to be a constant.
This thing, since its gap is 38
dollars and I only hold 1 sixth
of it,
it's going to pay me exactly 6
and 1 half more down here than
it pays here because the gap
instead of 38 will be 1 sixth of
that,
which will be 6 and 1 half.
So the gap will exactly match
that.
So added that to the Treasury's
constant payments I'm going to
get something over here and 6
and 1 half dollars more than
that down here.
But since I've paid the same
amount,
98.8, it's going to have to be
that that constant was exactly
right to make this be 100.6 and
107.11,
because both the 1 year
Treasury and the 30 year bond
were calculated by discounting
whatever their payments were
here and here by the same
prices,
this and this.
So there's a second way.
Instead of trading in the
derivatives market I could just
hold a combination of two bonds,
the 1 year Treasury and the 30
year 9 percent bond,
and I'd still be perfectly
hedged.
But then when I got to here I'd
want to change my mix.
I'd want to hold a different
1-year bond at a different
interest rate,
so I have to buy a new 1-year
bond and a different amount of
the 30-year non-callable bond,
9 percent bond,
but I could always reproduce
these same two payments.
So I don't have to hedge by
holding derivatives,
interest rate derivatives,
I can hedge by holding standard
bonds.
And I can tell at a glance how
much of the longer term bond to
hold because I just have to
match this gap in the prices
since the 1 year bond is always
going to pay the same thing up
and down.
Did that go too fast?
Yeah?
Student: I know it's
just
like>
but how did you figure out how
much of the 1-year bond to buy?
Prof: So I want to hold
1 sixth of the 30 year bond,
which cost me 140,
so 1 sixth of that is going to
cost me 23 dollars.
All right, now I want to also
hold a 1 year Treasury so that
the payment 1 sixth of 121 at
the top plus whatever the 1 year
Treasury pays me is equal to
100.6 and such that 1 sixth
times this value at the bottom,
oh, sorry.
It's 1 sixth this coupon is
paying.
Actually it wasn't 121.6.
It's a 9 percent bond.
I forgot its coupon,
very bad of me.
It won't change the numbers,
but.
So it's paying--I didn't write
it down.
So this thing is not paying 121.
It's also paying the coupon.
This is the present value of
what's left.
So it's paying 9 plus that.
So it's 130 and here it's 168.
The gap is still 38.
So I want 1 sixth of 130.
So 1 sixth of 130 costs--it's
still the same number.
It's 22.
I did bad arithmetic to begin
with so it's still 22.
No, sorry, it's 1 sixth of this
thing which is 140,
so it's 23, right.
Sorry.
That didn't change.
So the payment here is 130 and
the payment here is 168.
So 1 sixth of 130,
that's the up payment,
and this is 1 sixth of 168.
Now, I want that plus whatever
the 1 year Treasury gives me to
equal 100.6 up here and 107.11
down here.
That way I would have
replicated things and hedged
myself perfectly,
right?
But I don't have to figure out
what that 1 year Treasury is.
I think it's obvious.
All I have to do is say
subtract 23 from 98.8,
so I just have to buy 75.8
dollars worth of the 1 year
Treasury and that'll give me
exactly the right payoff.
Why is that?
Because this number 140.93
divided by 6 is exactly this
evaluated at this price,
1 half over 1.06 times this,
this is the price 1 half times
1 over 1.06.
All right, so that bond which
cost 140.53 how did I get 140.53
there?
I took the price of 1 dollar in
the up state,
which is it's 50 percent likely
discounted,
multiplying by its payoff 130,
plus 1 half discounted
multiplied by the payoff of 168.
This is 168 because it's a 9
percent bond.
So it's 1 sixth times 1
sixth--so if I get a sixth of
the bond it'll cost me 140.43
divided by 6 which is 23.
So what about the 1 year
Treasury?
That's going to give me some
payment, an additional payment
here and here,
namely 1.06 times whatever I
put in.
So you notice that the gap
between here and here since I've
multiplied by 1 sixth is exactly
this 6 and 1 half dollar gap.
So the total I have to spend is
98.8 over here,
so if I spend 23 dollars on the
Treasury and the remaining
amount--
23 dollars on the 30 year 9
percent bond,
the remaining amount of money
which is 75.8 on the Treasury I
will have spent this 98.8
dollars,
but then I have to get the same
payoffs.
Why is that?
Because they're all being
priced at the same prices,
so it's just the distributive
law of arithmetic.
If these payoffs times 1 sixth
plus the Treasury payoffs equal
100.6 and 107.11 then it must be
that the sum of the money I
spent on the 30 year 9 percent
bond,
plus the sum of the money I
spent on the Treasury has to
equal 98.8.
Therefore, I know that the
amount of money of the 98.8 I
spent on the 1 year Treasury was
98.8 minus the 23 I spent on the
30-year bond.
So that's how you can--so to
say it again just in a big
picture look.
There are two things that can
happen.
If you hold two bonds,
a 1-year Treasury and a 30-year
thing,
you're obviously going to be
able to match these two things
by holding the right proportion
of them.
That is just obvious.
And then less obvious is how
quickly I'm figuring out how
much of those two bonds to hold.
And the way I'm figuring it out
so quickly is because the 1-year
Treasury is paying the same
thing up and down,
so I have to get all the
variation out of the 30-year
bond,
so I have to hold the right
proportion of the 30-year bond
to get the same variation.
So in the very big picture if
you're trying to hedge some
instrument with another
instrument and a portfolio of
stuff,
much of which is certain,
and only one thing that's
risky,
the amount of the risky thing
you have to hold has to produce
as much variation as the thing
you're trying to hedge.
So the key is being able to
tell at a glance how much
variation each thing has then
you can tell in what proportion
to hold them.
And so the very last thing I
want to tell you today,
which is unfortunately going to
take me a few minutes,
is how traders look at
variation and can guess it
incredibly quickly.
So a trader could look at this
and guess without doing almost
any calculations what the right
hedge is.
So just like we did the
doubling rule I want to do the
variation rule of thumb.
And this is called duration and
convexity, or average life.
So I asked myself,
suppose I have this 30-year
bond, 30-year non-callable bond,
that's this one,
9 percent bond.
How could I guess,
kind of, what the variation in
price would be without having to
do,
you know, I've had to do this
very complicated backward
induction calculation.
Now, remember once the interest
rates go up here it's a random
walk so on average they're
pretty much,
not pretty much,
they're exactly what they were
here.
They start here.
They go up and down,
but on average they're still
here.
And over here they've gone down
so the average is lower going
forward.
In fact, it's exactly equal to
that.
So if you're a trader and there
was no uncertainty you would
know that the present value with
no uncertainty is going to be
the coupon divided by (1 the
interest rate) the coupon over
(1 the interest rate) squared
(in the last year) the coupon
over (1 the interest rate) to
the T 100 times [correction:
over]
(1 the interest rate) to the T.
That's the value of the bond.
Now, you sort of want to know
how much is that price going to
change when the interest rate
changes.
Well, at a glance,
I mean, you just take the
derivative.
What is dPV/dr?
It's going to be minus C over
(1 r) squared - 2 C over (1 r)
cubed - T times C over (1 r) to
the (T 1) - T times 100 divided
by (1 r) to the (T 1).
That's the derivative.
It looks like I'm making things
even more complicated,
you would think,
but this turns out to be not so
complicated,
because this is a number--so
let's put the minus on the
outside,
so I'll get rid of this.
This is a number which you can
sort of get in your head,
so let's try writing it.
Let's pull out one of the (1
r)s.
So it's minus 1 over (1 r)
times (C over (1 r) 2 C over (1
r) squared ...
T times (C 100) (that's the
last payment) over (1 r) to the
T).
Now, what is that?
Can you interpret that?
And the answer is yes you can
interpret that because what is
that?
That's saying these are all the
payments you're getting over the
life of the bond.
It's C, C and the last one's C
100.
This number that keeps coming
in front of them,
though, is the year in which
you're getting the payment.
This is in the first year.
I could put a 1 there.
This is the payment in the
second year.
There's a 2 here.
This is the payment in the Tth
year.
There's a T here.
You got that T from taking the
derivative of the denominator
here.
So it's like weighting the year
in which the payments come by
the value of those payments.
So in the first year the value
is C.
The present value is C over (1
r).
In the second year the payment
is C,
but discounted,
C over (1 r) squared,
and the last year the total
payment is C 100,
but you had to discount it by
(1 r) to the Tth.
So this is just like taking the
average year in which the
present value flows actually
come.
If I divided this now by the
present value of--
the present value,
these numbers down here,
C over this C over this squared
C 100 over this to the Tth,
those are all weights
multiplying the year in which
the payments come.
They add up to the present
value.
So basically I've just got a
weighted average of what year
the payments come in.
This is called the average life.
This thing in here is the
average life because I've
multiplied the year in which the
payments come by the present
value of the cash flows there
and then I've made those
multipliers add up to 1 by
dividing by the PV.
See, this in parenthesis,
all these terms are the things
multiplying the year in which
the thing came.
So if I add up all these
coefficients here I'm just
getting the present value.
So now the coefficients add up
to 1.
So I'm just taking an average
of the year in which the thing
came and that's what the average
life is,
but that's equal to the
derivative of the present value
divided by the present value.
So it's--the percentage change
in the present value is the
average year in which the
payments come.
So let's just think about it.
Suppose you have a 10-year bond?
It pays C, C,
C, C, C, and then 100 at the
very end.
What do you think the average
life is?
Well, if there were no
discounting the average life
wouldn't be 5 because there's
such a huge payment in the end.
The average life would be 8 or
9, but there is discounting so
this thing at the end won't
count as much.
So the average life is probably
7.
If it's a 30 year bond,
the average life,
you're going to get C,
C, C, C, and then all the way
at the end you're going to get C
100.
Well, if the payments were all
equal and no discounting it
would be 15,
but there's a huge amount of
discounting so that last payment
is really pretty irrelevant,
so probably--so it's not clear
which way it goes,
probably the average life will
be less than 15.
So you can see just by looking
at the bond,
and I'm ending with this
thought, by looking at the bond
itself you can figure out what
the average life is.
So a trader,
just by a little experience and
common sense,
can figure out the average
life.
I mean, here are all the
payments the way they're coming.
They're coming evenly across
the whole history of the bond
with something at the end,
so the average life is probably
a little bit over the average,
but if you go way off,
you push the final payment too
far to the end then it's
becoming negligible,
it's almost irrelevant,
and so the average life by
discounting will probably be
before the average.
So a 10-year bond probably has
an average life of 7,
a 30-year bond maybe has an
average life of 12 or 13.
Once you know the average life,
you just have to hold bonds in
proportion to their average
lives.
The dollar amount you put in
each bond to hedge it is just
proportional to its average
life.
So that's how a trader,
without having to do any
arithmetic,
can kind of guess how much of
the 30 year bond will it take to
hedge a 10 year bond,
and how much of a--so which has
a higher average life?
The longer the bond the higher
the average life,
the more sensitive it is to
interest rate changes so the
less of it you need to hedge
your position,
so if you hold the 30 year bond
you don't have to hold that much
of it,
1 sixth of it,
in order to hedge this
mortgage.
The mortgage has a very short
average life because it's
prepaying so quickly.
So it's not going to last very
long.
So this is an amazing
connection between average life
and sensitivity to interest
rate.
And average life is something
you can guess.
Sensitivity to interest rate is
something you have to do huge
calculations for,
but the two are almost the
same.
So in the problem set we'll see
if you can do it.
I asked you a couple problems
to do with average life,
so.